in life all we can do is our vest and
when we do our vest we deserve to be
happy with ourselves this is absolutely
the truth however the challenge with
that statement is everyone's best is
different so sometimes it can be hard to
feel good about it everyone is always
dealing with different things in
different places at different times at
this exact moment no one else can see
the world the same way you are seeing it
you will always be dealing with your own
unique mess of stuff at your own unique
place in time and space so your best
will not always be someone else's best
and someone else's best will not always
be your best and we must learn how to be
okay with that this does not mean that
in moments when we are trying hard at
something we care about but aren't doing
as well as we'd like that we don't push
a little bit harder or a little bit
smarter in an attempt to find out what
our best really could be but this does
mean that when we can honestly say that
we tried our best we deserve to be proud
of ourself no matter what the outcome is
sometimes doing our best means
overcoming hard challenges accomplishing
important things and achieving big goals
but sometimes our best is just going to
be getting out of bed in the morning but
in doing this so long as we are doing
our best we are still overcoming hard
challenges accomplishing important
things and achieving big goals even if
it seems like the world might not agree
today if you did your best be proud of
yourself not because you did better than
others not because you made a certain
amount of money or did something
successfully at a job or at school but
because you did your best even if that
just means getting out of bed and facing
the world
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder